welcome everyone i'm susie valdez and i
will be your lab roots moderator for
today's event
thank you for joining us for a
presentation titled exploring the great
unknown characterizing complex mixtures
of
environmental contaminants it's my
pleasure to introduce you to dr
shane snyder executive director of nang
environment and water research institute
and the president's chair in water
technologies
for complete biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
if any questions arise during this
presentation we encourage you to submit
those questions in our q a box our
speaker will address your questions
following his presentation
please join me now in welcoming dr shane
snyder i will now
turn the presentation to him welcome sir
i'm going to try to paint a picture
today and tie it to some very recent
events that we've even
dealt with here in singapore related to
emerging contaminants or those say next
generation type of contaminants that we
may not be able to detect
easily with current technologies and
what are some of the ways to continue
to ensure public health as we deal with
alternative water sources be it
potable water reuse or even sea water
desalination so um again i
certainly hope that in the future we can
meet live in person and uh
have more of uh interdisciplinary um
collaborations so
uh as professor tong mentioned i'm i've
been uh
here at ntu now for uh two and a half
years i feel very
honored to be here in singapore which
has a quite rich history in terms of its
water management and its its drive
towards water security and independence
and it really began with the early
founders of singapore in fact
lee kuang yu once said that every policy
had to bend to the knees of water
survival indeed
we can see today the impacts of droughts
on economies
and food supplies and even in our
ability to produce and distribute
electrical power so
here we are in southeast asia um i know
our friends
in hong kong aren't so far away but it's
hard to even see us
on this dot right this small tip of
malaysia
but we actually struggle quite a bit
with water
and water security in fact by some
rankings
one in 2015 stated that perhaps
singapore may be
even the world's most water-stressed
country
as a small island nation it is
difficult to capture our rain water
in our limited catchment limited land
area which of course that land is quite
valuable
likely similar scenario in hong kong
but over the years we've been striving
and making gains
but if we look at the region more
broadly and something i really hadn't
thought through when i was
in the united states is how big
southeast asia actually is
so here in southeast asia we're home to
up to 650 million people
and the population growth has been quite
profound
often quadrupling in population some of
our countries
uh over since 1960 with the largest
population centers
of course being in the philippines and
indonesia but even singapore has seen
quite dramatic growth over that period
of time
in fact if you look at singapore in the
1960s at 582 square kilometers
and by 2018 had increased its land
capacity by about 23 percent through
engineering
but along with that of course comes a
consequential
demand for water and that demand
continues to increase
not only with population but largely
with industrial
needs as well thus singapore has
employed
potable water reuse in the form of new
water
we import water still from malaysia and
we've built
new desalination facilities and
continued to expand
but as all of us know there are new
challenges on the horizon be it in water
quality or water quantity
uh this particular news article is from
2014
where singapore has seen the driest
month in
since 1869 and
what this background is showing you see
the grass is actually dead which
in the garden city is very unusual even
the trees are beginning to die
from this lack of rainfall and of course
that same drought was also experienced
in malaysia our neighboring country just
across the bridge
to the north and it came to such an
extent
that water rationing began to happen and
certain parts of kuala lumpur
ran out of water completely
and of course this isn't unique to to
southeast asia or asia
uh i'll show one article from zimbabwe
and another from brazil
where over the last five or so years
they've also seen
unparalleled droughts which again cause
disruption not only to the water supply
of course but also
to power in hydroelectric so there's a
lot of new challenges i expect that
as the world's climate continues to
evolve we may have to be thinking about
how to deal
with the water crisis and to look at
alternative sources
and particularly today i want to address
potable water reuse where we
intentionally engineering take our waste
water
and convert it into high value even very
high purity water
through engineering another example from
california where i spent a lot of my
time when i was in this
western united states and just to show
how fast things can change in 2011
one of these primary reservoirs for
northern california
looked quite full quite abundant and
within three years that same reservoir
was essentially
completely diminished and it caused not
only disruptions to the municipal system
but it caused large disruptions
to the economy with some companies
actually threatening to leave california
if they could not secure their water
supply so around that time
the governor of california did something
that was quite surprising i think to
many of us especially even to me
working in the industry was to mandate
the development of water quality
criteria or water recycling criteria
for direct potable reuse so in singapore
we use
indirect potable reuse whereby we purify
to a high degree our waste water put it
back into our reservoirs where it's
blended
then pull it out and treat it through
conventional or advanced drinking water
treatment facilities but
in california they're moving quickly
towards this idea of direct potable
reuse whereby
we would not have a typical drinking
water plant but rather
an advanced water recycling facility
that can directly place that finished
product
into the distribution system for
drinking and
actually economically it makes a lot of
sense so what's the big challenge well
public perception for one um often i
think rightfully so the public has
tied the history of pollution even if we
think back
on the plagues that that struck the
world and even into the
early 1900s many of these were
waterborne disease
and of course reports such as emerging
contaminants that
i've enjoyed working on endocrine
disruptors or pharmaceuticals
but again the public facing some degree
of skepticism about whether or not
we can safely and reliably build systems
that have high redundancy
and are protective against not only the
chemicals that are regulated but
these rather unknown or emerging
contaminants
so again just a couple articles you can
see that we're in the in the news in
america you know is my
tap water safe to drink finding
different levels of industrial chemicals
in
in the water for americans and of course
many of you may have heard about the
unfortunate
incident in flint michigan involving
lead and the leaching of lead into
drinking water so the public
has become skeptical of at least in
north america
of the drinking water in general let
alone as we try to move forward
and utilize alternative sources of water
such as water recycling
so a very recent incident here in
singapore this is from the 23rd of july
it kept my
phone quite busy for a few days in
certain parts of singapore and in
malaysia
the water began to have an off smell the
water actually smelled kind of sweet
like the fruit pandan and was reported
by customers both in singapore and
malaysia
and of course the the agency were
fortunate of a very progressive water
agency for the nation's singapore pub
has already
begun to look at ways to enhance the
treatment process
and i like this last statement they note
that at current
screening technologies really do not
allow
for the detection of trace amounts in
this case of an
organic chemical tetrahydrofuran which
was responsible
for that odor i mentioned before so
what we realize is that our water
systems are susceptible
and regardless of of how advanced the
treatment may be
there are always be certain chemicals
that are able to evade the system
and we have to think more holistically
about the health impacts if any
and how we can better detect and deal
with
emerging contaminants
so i was very impressed when this thf
spill happened in malaysia and detected
in singapore it's interesting that the
first
detector was not an instrument it was
people's nose so the human nose
is still hard to beat but regardless
very quickly singapore pub was able to
utilize their analytical capabilities
and determine the the chemical as being
tetrahydrofuran or thf so i think
even though online sensors may not be
able to immediately detect a chemical
such as thf
we do have the tools to very quickly
identify
almost anything that you can imagine in
the water supply
but this begs the bigger question are we
looking for the right things are we
really
understanding what has the most impacts
to our treatment systems to
public health and are important for our
monitoring systems
so what is it we should monitor for and
i've spent a lot of time on various
expert panels both for the for the
federal government
us epa and especially in california
around their water reuse and this
topic goes round and round even with
the time i've spent working with the
world health organization
it's very difficult to say what are the
most
important substances to monitor
so just think about it if we have say an
effluent be it industrial or municipal
and we just want to say is it safe or
not safe that is an extremely difficult
question to answer in fact it's not
really
an analytical question it's more of a
biological or
toxicological question so what is it
in this complex mixture that's important
to monitor
so where do we see examples so i just
show a few from southeast asia if we
look at
metro manila and satellite image you can
see that there are black plumes that are
coming from
the urban water systems it's a highly
dense system
and and definitely making strides to
improve the environmental quality but
yet
definitely a challenging environment so
what are the
substances if any in these plumes that
may be
impactful to aquatic health or even to
human health
in lake mead nevada this is the water
supply for the city of las vegas nevada
but also the water supply for about 30
million people
in the downstream of the colorado river
in the united states
in the early 2000s we had this as i'm
showing here
epic algal bloom never before seen
in the history of the reservoir and
lo and behold we were surprised that
this included toxic strains of
algae including cylindrospermopsin so
we are dealing with a lot of unexpected
consequences
through climate change and urbanization
and industrialization this is an example
of an
acid mine drainage in pennsylvania is my
home state where i was born and my
family lives
and surprisingly this is not ancient
history this is 2009.
so we are we have a lot of of room to
grow and we have a lot
of engineering and analytical uh work
ahead to better protect the environment
and public health
so that begs the question so how many
chemicals are there
in use today and again spending uh quite
a bit of time on the epa
science advisory board and in the world
health organization i can tell you that
we can barely keep up
with the chemical inventory that is do
we even know
how many chemicals are actually in
commerce
and do we think that all the chemicals
in commerce have been tested
that's absolutely not true in fact the
vast majority have not been tested
for endpoints relevant to drinking water
or
even environmental discharge
and at least in the united states
there's some effort to
to try to better characterize these
chemicals through a series of biological
testing
but even if that type of regulation were
to be employed
and we estimate it could take centuries
to get through the current inventory of
chemicals
let alone the very rapid pace of
chemical discovery that we
see today so for me and my
my journey really began back in the
1990s i was a graduate student
at michigan state university i worked
with a very well-known guy
professor john geezy and we were faced
with a
amazing discovery and that is
that fish living in the effluents of las
vegas the city of las vegas
were experiencing what we would call
estrogenic
impact in other words the fish were
obviously exposed to chemicals which
could
impact their reproductive system and
that discovery was actually made by the
national agency the u.s geological
survey
but michigan state university and i
myself as a student
became quite engaged because what we
didn't know was what was causing it
and there were a lot of hypotheses but
nobody was quite sure
and of course this reservoir lake mead
as i said serves the drinking water for
millions of people
so it caused a tremendous amount of
public
outcry and and concern so
this is a type of water reuse i mean the
city of las vegas is discharging
its wastewater back into its own
drinking water reservoir
so that they have enough water supply to
sustain a very thirsty arid city
so january 1st 1998
our study got some amazing publicity
perhaps ironically
in environmental science and technology
so
what we were able to do and at least
attributed in this article for being the
first time
in north american history was to
tie the effect that had been seen in the
fish
to the occurrence of natural and
synthetic estrogens
the natural ones being primarily the
estrogen that
all of us carry of course women more
than men but but
all animals have and the synthetic
estrogen hormone
a dinoestrodiol which is primarily used
as an oral
birth control medication but has other
medical applications as well
so how are we able to do this this is
again in the in the late 1990s
and we were we published two pieces of
work around that study were published in
environmental science and technology and
what we were able to do the way we were
able to figure
this out was to actually combine
analytical measurements
with biological cellular assays
so what i'm showing here in the screen
is a little tricky to see perhaps but
the chromatogram is actually liquid
chromatography with fluorescence
the white lines represent fractions so
we used a fraction collector to collect
a fraction of that lc chromatogram
and then we tested it in the very bottom
pane you can see what i call
e2 max which is the percent of estradiol
or natural
estrogen induction in a human breast
cancer cell
so we had genetically engineered human
breast cancer cells to produce light
so when a chemical or mixture of
chemicals
would bind to the human endogenous
estrogen receptor
it would cause a light production that
we could easily measure with a
plate scanning special photometer so if
you kind of look at the left pane you
can see this high degree of
estrogenicity it looks like what 90
percent
occurring somewhere between say five and
looks like 8 minutes
a little bit less around the 10 minute
mark and not really a
lot of estrogenicity in fact the red
bars being the
95 confidence interval and
if you look carefully at the
chromatogram on the left screen you see
another peak and there's a very large
peak it's off
of the linear range which turns out to
be non-alphenol which is a known
estrogen a synthetic estrogen
and that's the chemical we thought was
causing the effect we were
as a student i was quite certain about
it but if you look to the right what we
realized
is that it didn't really match up and it
took us some time and we were really
following
in the footsteps of professor john
sumter in the united kingdom and others
who realize that actually e2 being the
natural estrogen
of all humans and ee2 being a thino
estradiol
which is the primary again
pharmaceutical used for oral birth
control
we're accounting for essentially all of
the estrogenicity so
again the way we are able to solve this
is this combination
of both biological and analytical
technologies
i mentioned it already but just to show
a little bit of how this genetically
engineered cell line works
we expose the cells to a bit
of the chemical extract extracted from
the water
generally in a solvent like dmso or
methanol
and then of course the chemicals if
they're capable of migrating through the
cellular membrane the nuclear membrane
they can become bound to the in this
case of the
estrogen receptor and if so the estrogen
receptor elements
which are endogenous to the cell then
upregulate the
luciferin gene that we've inserted into
the cell
and when we add external luciferase we
have a light production
which is easy to quantify so this again
remember this is in the 1990s
i'll show you we've come a long way
since the 1990s
and again just just another news article
from 2006
again this kind of findings in the water
really did
become quite a concern for the public so
as we continue down this path towards
more and more direct
type potable water reuse we have to
remember these incidents which happened
not a hundred years ago but just you
know 10 to 20 years ago
and my final my final uh word about this
particular estrogen
was that you know we're talking about
potential impacts to humans which
probably is
unlikely at the concentrations that are
out there but
it has been clearly demonstrated that
those same levels that we detected
could cause even extinction to certain
species of fish this was published
in proceedings of the national academy
of science in 2007 where
an entire lake in canada was dosed with
around
seven to nine parts per trillion of the
thin western diol which is in the same
general
range of what we were discovering in the
environment so these can have
environmental consequence
so what's next what's the next big thing
i'm showing data now that's
10 i guess even 20 years old at this
point in time
i think it's best if we just back up
from chemical by chemical thinking
and just accept the fact that almost any
chemical
in commerce in our house produced
whether synthetically or even natural
chemicals
have a degree of propensity to enter
into our sewer system and subsequently
into the environment even to our
drinking water
be it pharmaceuticals of course
pesticides
but also even oxyhalides like
perchlorate which has caused quite a bit
of concern
and we certainly shouldn't forget about
the pathogens
today my laboratory here in singapore
spends quite a bit of our time
monitoring the covid uh virus the sars
cove ii virus
in our wastewater system as an indicator
for the degree of infectivity i realize
around the world a lot of people are
doing that so
that's another example of how our sewers
in fact do carry a lot of
information and also some risk
the other thing to remember is that
chemical discovery continues you know
even
at any point in time when we say we may
we can look at a certain list of
chemicals in commerce
we actually have been estimated to add
up to 15
000 new structures per day
into the chemical abstract service so
you can see that you know uh
in 50 years over 100 million chemicals
were added
to that list you can see how rapid that
discovery has become in recent
times say from 2005 to 2015.
and uh in 2014 more chemicals were added
to
the chem abstract registry than in all
the years from
1965 to 1990 and that trend continues
so how do we come how do we begin to try
to get our
arms around uh methodologies to
characterize and protect public
and environmental health well of course
we will never
in my opinion stop doing targeted
quantification
and the tools in our that we have
available today are better than ever
our triple quadrupole mass spectrometers
with liquid and gas interfaces of course
inorganics by things like uh inductively
coupled plasma ms
or ion chromatography we have incredible
tools
that even when i was a student were
nearly unimaginable today they're
becoming more and more
routine but the the area i'm most
fascinated about
are the non-targeted so how do we even
begin to think about
characterizing the unknown and that's
how do we get a ahead
of the estrogens or of perchlorate
before
they release into the environment and
cause an impact to health
and we do this mainly through high
resolution mass spectrometry
and various hyphenated techniques and i
also want to explore with you a bit more
about what i mentioned in cell bioassay
so
one of i think one of the leading groups
in in this area had been in california
because of the mandate i showed you from
the governor
and the drive towards more potable reuse
and direct potable reuse even
so they convened um a series of expert
panels and i've been
fortunate enough i guess fortunate
enough to be a member of several of
those panels and this is just
an example of one of the reports that we
uh shared
and what we recommended to the
government was a tiered approach so tier
1
being the most inexpensive most rapid
and preferably online techniques to
monitor water quality so i'm going to
show you examples of these in a minute
but you can imagine things like online
doc
uv 254 fluorescence
and other things like conductivity etc
here too is what we would like to call
our targeted analysis
very similar to what we do in a
regulatory context but we have
a new way of looking at it where we call
indicators or indicator species where we
pick
representative chemistries and we use
them instead of trying to monitor for
everything
and in the third tier these are our most
novel and most challenging and frankly
most expensive techniques
we begin to peer more into this unknown
world we recommended these with lesser
frequency
but yet to think carefully about how
these different tiers can combine
and if you're interested in that i'm not
going to go further into it but you can
read about that
in this report that i cite below
i don't want to dwell on this but it's
incredible to me how fast analytical
technology has grown from when i was a
student
in one of our publications we were
extracting 100 liters of water
to try to quantify into the say tens of
parts per trillion
today we don't even need extraction um
here even in newry we just received a
even newer instrument that i'm sure than
i'm showing here
or we can just inject a few microliters
of water with no treatment
and quantify easily into single digit or
even sub
parts per trillion so it is getting
faster and i think the quality of the
data also is beginning to improve
so how do we pick these chemicals let's
just take a look at some examples now
i'll put together now some case studies
so again this this actually does come
from the state of california expert
report where we suggested
looking at the different applications
but more importantly the structure so
those of us
who are chemists here can appreciate
that whether a chemical is a
pharmaceutical or
disinfection byproduct or a
pesticide whatever doesn't really matter
what matters is is it toxic
and part of that is based on its
structure so how does it move through
water
solubility volatility and its impact to
health
so we said let's look at a very
structural diversity including
specifically the structures shown in
this blue
color column
and then look at your monitoring data so
i'm just showing a study that
my research team had done where we were
monitoring a wastewater treatment
effluent
bound for water reuse in southern
arizona
united states and after uh quarterly
monitoring we were able to put together
a table like this where we show
to the left the chemicals that occurred
at the highest frequency but also the
highest concentration
and as you go to the right chemicals
with lesser frequency and lower
concentration now
this tells us nothing about the toxicity
i want to be clear
but it's a great way to do indicator
occurrence
so why is that important well if we pick
things like on the
on the sorry the left of the screen like
sucralose an artificial sweetener
or tcpp which is a flame retardant
we can begin to look at the ratio of
these compounds and we know
if wastewater human influence is
occurring if there's a
even a treatment failure we can detect
that without measuring the whole gamut
so we can begin to build
relationships that actually make the
monitoring program a bit
less rigorous so i just show some
examples of chemicals that we
generally pick as indicators to
represent
broader classes
one thing that's important and i can't
stress enough is of course
the indicators that you select need to
be geographically
uh representative so
this is a little bit tricky to see this
i'll just say quickly this is again some
data from southern arizona here that i'm
showing now
and if we compare that to some
monitoring data
from singapore and we just look at some
of the most
widely detected compounds we see some
similarities
like sucralose is common but we also see
some very big differences it's
interesting
that the type of x-ray contrast media we
see predominantly in the united states
iopanmedol
is a different structure than what we
see in singapore which is io
hexel both of them are iodinated
contrast media
but apparently one is favored in the in
the us
as compared to singapore so it is
important to ground this
in your local scenario
so what's another important way to look
at the indicator we want it to be
representative
of water treatment efficacy and to do
that
we want to look at the particular
process i think i'll show you two
processes the first
is biological so say secondary
wastewater treatment so the dominant
chemical attenuation will be through
biotransformation or microbial
degradation
and through resorption or binding into
the biosolids
so i have here um you know come some
categories we came up with
if we see this red box with the members
the carbamazepine meprobanmade primadone
those are all pharmaceuticals
or tcep which is a flame retardant and
again sucralose being the artificial
sweetener
they are not well bound to the biosolids
and they're also very resistant to
biotransformation
that means that they are ubiquitous as i
showed previously
in nearly every wastewater treatment
plant certainly in the united states
but also commonly detected in other
parts of the world
depending on usage likewise if you kind
of look down
in the lower right corner you see
triclosan and fluoxetine fluoxetine
being a drug also known as prozac
we really don't see them that frequently
in the wastewater because they are quite
rapidly bio degraded and then they're
quite
well bound to the biosolids so if we see
those at high concentrations
it may also tell us that something has
went awry
in the treatment train another quick
example
and all these examples i'm showing are
published so if you're interested i'm
happy to provide the reference
in ozonation we can do the same thing we
can begin to look at
reactivity and things like carbamazepine
which are
obviously resistant to secondary
wastewater treatment
are very highly susceptible to ozone
whereas if we look at this group four of
iopamidol
it is very resistant to ozone
and it makes a great indicator if we're
looking at the process
of whether or not the treatment process
is effective for ozonation
and i guess one more example would be
around uv
hydrogen peroxide and advanced oxidation
again the same story so i won't go
reading through this but
we're showing something a little bit
extra here i'm going to transition into
which is fluorescence so on the right
side
we can actually see a change in
fluorescence
it's better to see it mathematically
than graphically but significant changes
as we increase the dose
and hydrogen peroxide so it's another
way to track the efficacy and we call
that a surrogate approach
so i'll spend a few minutes uh
discussing surrogates such as that last
example of fluorescence
so let's step back to ozone again one of
my most favorite technologies
very powerful oxidant and very complex
chemistry
and we know that ozone is an incredible
disinfectant especially for viruses
like like the covid responsible virus
but also for more resilient organisms
such as cryptosporidium
here are showing an example for e coli
and you can see that the ozone in fact
quite quite apparently is able to
oxidize the the cellular membrane and
destroy
inactivate the bacteria
but we found some really interesting
applications for ozone at very low doses
where we can actually begin to control
reverse osmosis membrane fouling
so we've done quite a bit of work has
been published again
previously where at relatively low doses
we
can have a substantial reduction in
fouling
this was published in the journal
membrane science a few years back
but we are even looking at how to get
higher recovery through brine recycling
and with relatively low doses of ozone
we get a much higher
or lesser flux decline i should say i
don't want to go deep into this
but this it's a bit challenging we also
saw this same phenomenon for
microfiltration fouling using different
types of membranes so
again relatively low doses of ozone
yielding pretty substantial gains in
reduction
of membrane fouling or flux decline
however no good deed goes unpunished
um in california they decided to
explore this at full scale which we
would have cautioned
maybe jumping that quick but nonetheless
a full-scale priosin ozone system was
imp
employed to help reduce membrane fouling
particularly the mfuf systematic water
recycling plant
but unfortunately some of the membranes
became very brittle
quickly and shattered and caused
quite a bit of damage so we wanted to
explore why would that happen and the
main problem is trying to control the
ozone dose
probably many of you realize that we
control ozone by ozone residual and that
is
we add enough ozone to the water we can
measure dissolved ozone
and control the process but for these
gains
both in contaminant oxidation and
membrane
valine control we don't need ozone
residual we don't want
ozone residuals so how do we control it
and better protect
the downstream processes at least one of
the answers will be in fluorescence i
think that there's a very
uh good future in controlling water
treatment not only
for ozone but other processes based on
the intrinsic
fluorescence this is not fluorescence
from emerging contaminants but
fluorescence
from the natural organic matter so here
we can see
ozone in a recycled water we can see the
control
before any ozone and as we add
relatively low doses well up to a fairly
high dose at six
but we can see a very clear bleaching
effect
and we looked at that more closely we
can actually see this not only for
fluorescence which is on the right with
tf or total fluorescence
we can also see this in uv absorption or
uv
transmission which i show on the left
now
the benefit of fluorescence is it's more
sensitive more sensitive
and somewhat better linear correlation
not always
but the sensitivity and the dynamic
range for fluorescence
is definitely better than uv but uv also
works quite well
so let's get into the most fun part and
start to wrap up here but
what about as we get even deeper so we
know we have the indicator approach the
surrogate approach we can use even for
process control
but let's take a look at non-targeted
analysis
so many of you probably know about
nitroso dimethylamine or ndma
this is a very controversial generally
disinfection byproduct but it's a
chemical that's been studied in
literature for a very long time
it is a well-known carcinogen there's no
doubt about that it's been used
as a positive control if you want to
cause cancer
in an animal you can give it enough ndma
and it will
generally develop tumors so when we were
looking at this concept of preozonation
for membrane fouling control
we unfortunately realized that another
consequence was that
as we added ozone to the
secondary or tertiary effluent we form
very high levels
of ndma and to put that into perspective
the world health world health
organization's guideline is 100 parts
per trillion
california has an action limit of 10
parts per trillion
and the us epa has identified a one in a
million
cancer risk of 0.7 parts per trillion or
700 parts per quadrillion hard to even
imagine
and you can see that as we added ozone
we far exceeded
any known guideline for ndma
so that begs the question well if we
formed ndma what else do we form
and to look at that we begin to explore
high-resolution mass spectrometry here
we show
liquid chromatography with with
quadrupole time of flight analysis
could also be done should be done also
with gas chromatography
i'll just show you an lc example now so
this is that same water and we're
looking at four doses of ozone
and if you look at these chromatograms
you may think or i would think
they look very similar you might be able
to identify something different
but probably not but if we begin to
statistically look if we get begin to
use the power of pca type software
we can begin to realize that these
waters are dramatically different in
composition
so here's a pca plot of that same exact
data and you can see they group
quite well to each other but yet they
are much different
than each other within the doses or the
control
so we can begin to look at this in
different heat maps we can see that some
compounds are formed some compounds are
removed
and we can go into very deep dive
analysis
so i just want to show you let's let's
take that apart and look at one chemical
we discovered which is benzotriazole
this is a very common anti-corrosion
agent it's
essentially ubiquitous in wastewater
because it's used in detergents
and when we add ozone we can say well
wow it's very
quickly disappears it because it is no
longer present after ozone
so what we did we actually coupled our
ozone reactor
directly to the quadrupole time of
flight mass spectrometer
and this red line that i'm trying to
show here in this top chromatogram
is the moment we added ozone this is
like a real time
near real-time connection between the
ozone reactor and the mass spectrometer
so what we see is as we add ozone the
benzotriosol begins to
decay it begins to go down in
concentration but we see this green line
which is a transformation product
which is beginning to form if we look at
the bottom where we zoom in closer we
see that actually
several different transformation
products form but one in particular that
we form
is this compound the dicarbaldehyde
so it's quite stable so in the drinking
water the benzotriazole would be
if you will gone after ozone but instead
we would be consuming the dicarbaldehyde
so that begs the question which one is
more risky to human health maybe none
hopefully not but to say that we've
removed benzotriazole well
that's not quite accurate we have
actually just transformed it
into a byproduct and that is true of
nearly every oxidation process
rarely do we mineralize organic
structures to carbon dioxide
but rather we transform them into
something different
and we hope that that something
different is something not toxic and
hopefully maybe biodegradable by a
downstream biofilter but not always
a couple quick examples to drive home
the point
remember the pharmaceutical i mentioned
is quite ubiquitous in wastewater
carbamazepine again just using a very
low dose of ozone at one milligram
we see that the carbamazepine drops in
its magnitude
but we immediately see a transformation
product that forms
if we look deeper into the mass spec
data i won't get into that but
what we see is the formation of a
transformation product called bqm
and bqm is actually known to be toxic
to to human health at certain
concentrations so
again we'd eliminate it if you will or
transformed
carbamazepine but we formed a known
byproduct
uh that is uh in fact toxic at high
concentration
so i'm running low on time i'm going to
go through this last example yet
in the last few minutes to try to put
this all together now this was work we
did a few years back and published
in esnt where we had an interesting
discovery uh
i already mentioned some of the
advantages of bioassays but of course
it's the ability to screen more broadly
than we can with just analytical
chemistry
so we did an interesting study with a
company out of
stanford california that had essentially
the whole human genome
available as plasmids to transfect cells
to look at different
toxicities and we did all kinds of
endpoints but i just want to show
endocrine disrupting
chemicals for an example in this screen
here in this panel to the left you see
g-r-a-r-e-r er
gr is glucocorticoid receptor activity
ars
androgen like male hormone and er is
estrogen like i talked about before
and what we saw was relatively little
estrogen this roger road
wastewater treatment plant is a quite
antiquated uh trickling filter system
which has since been
um destroyed and rebuilt as an advanced
system
but what we were really not expecting
was this high
degree of glucocorticoid activity or gr
and we were very surprised that every
time we applied
uv treatment processes the
toxicities seem to go down dramatically
this is a log two
scale so these are quite high levels of
induction
so this is something that we had not
seen before um there was very
little literature on this so we wanted
to explore it more deeply
first of all of course i always tell my
students always start with the lit
review
we're quite surprised to see that
glucocorticoids are actually
the most widely prescribed the most by
concentration
at least in some countries as compared
to estrogens i talked about before or
even the the male hormones
androgens or progestins the fat
glucocorticoids are nearly
uh three times uh higher than some of
the other
estrogens the same is true in america
and we have an interesting thing that
happened in the united states in 2014
the u.s food and drug administration
approved
two nasal sprays one that i actually
continue to use most most nights which
contain
uh glucocorticoid steroids so before
this you had to get them from your
doctor prescription
in 2014 they became over the counter
so we had this toxicity i showed on the
first screen
so what did we do well we went through
that same basic workflow we screened the
samples with the bioassay
then we would fractionate in this case
by liquid chromatography
we also did size exclusion
chromatography
we would test each fraction when we had
a fraction with activity
we'd go back to the mass spectrometer
and we would try to figure out
what is causing that toxicity
again you know that same kind of
workflow with the statistical analyses
and on the right
you can start to see the identities of
some of the compounds
that were present and causing toxicity
so once we had a list of chemicals we
needed better quantification so we had
to go back
to the lc triple quadrupole and build a
more
specific more accurate way to quantify
the substances in the environment
so when we put the data together and
again this was published in the s
t we get an interesting distribution of
different wastewater treatment plant
effluents
and what we see very rapidly is this
chemical i'm going to call this tca for
short
that's highlighted represented between
50 and say 75
percent of the glucocorticoid receptor
loading
but what that doesn't tell us is about
the toxicity and that was the most
uh amazing part which i'll show now
so in the bioac again this is a human
cell
construct with a glucocorticoid receptor
with a reporter gene
we are able to test this different
glucocorticoid compounds
and these are logarithmic scales so you
can see that some of these things are
extremely
potent very toxic if you will and some
are
far less orders of magnitude apart so on
the right
we convert this to what we call relative
effective potency
and the reason dexamethasone has a one
is that was our positive control up
until this study
we thought that dexamethasone was the
most powerful
glucocorticoid so it became our standard
and we normalized
one but what you can see quite quickly
below
the dexamethasone is the tca at 2.2
meaning it was 2.2
times more i would loosely use the word
toxic but bioactive
than was the dexamethasone and this one
down here called cl
beta-sol propionate was 37
times more powerful more potent than our
positive control
this is how we begin to do the mass
balance
in terms of the treatment we could see
again that ozone was
effective but at relatively higher doses
but uv was extremely effective at even
ex
low doses even doses at disinfection
level
ultraviolet was effective
so where did this leave us where does
this take us
well today we're moving more and more
forward into
new types of new generations of of
platforms
that can go far beyond the work i showed
even from the last five years
uh here in our laboratory in singapore
my my team
is doing quite a bit of work with
zebrafish
embryos these are considered in vitro up
until a point where the fish are
sacrificed before they become
juveniles and we can do a lot of work on
micro
array looking at the genetics gene
expression assays
and we show down here we can even
genetically engineer the fish
so that they can fluoresce and even in
different colors if you will
for different organ systems such as the
neurons or the kidney or the liver
system
it's a pretty amazing technology we have
that can be fully utilized to screen our
water
and i should also add that this
technology was not developed
i think with environmental applications
in mind it was developed
to look for pharmaceutical discovery
we're just
applying applying it in a new way to
better screen both
water also air even soil samples
and when i came into ntu one of the
things i was just most impressed with
just to give you an idea of where we're
heading
is that some of our team members from
our medical school here at ntu
were actually growing organoids and in
this case they're growing a kidney
organoid and you can if you look closely
you can actually see that this
organoid actually has different tubules
it's growing blood vessels is beginning
to look in a very small scale
like a miniature human kidney and so
kidney has been a
target vessel for disinfection
byproducts in fact
there have been several papers that
attribute high levels of disinfection
byproducts with
incidents of kidney cancer so this
allows us to study
that effect in a new way without using
mice without using animal testing
in vitro with human cells with human
organs or organoids if you will
and i think that that future looks
extremely bright
and should be employed by the water
industry
so we're also seeing this is actually
getting a bit dated at 2014
but these these types of in vitro
bioassays are actually gaining more and
more traction
this article talks about not only in
vitro but in silico
or modeling whereby we are getting
better and better at predicting human
toxicity or
even aquatic uh life form toxicity
without the need for for animal testing
we will never
get our answers from traditional animal
testing it's too slow
it's too labor intensive and the
mixtures are just too daunting so i
think
this combination of in vitro work bio
assays
and analytical testing with high
resolution mass particularly
will really take us to to a better
understanding and i think
it will also help us gain public trust
and public acceptance
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
thank you dr snyder for that outstanding
presentation
and we will now move to the live q a
portion of the presentation
as a reminder please submit your
questions via the q and a
box and i would like to now welcome
mr mauricius marquise del santos
from new we a e b c who will be joining
us for our live q a
welcome mauricious
mauricious our first question is what
are the challenges
of doing unknowns screening with current
analytical technologies
and mauricius i'm so sorry but we can't
actually hear you
can you do me a favor and turn your
volume back on
and while you're doing that i want to
thank our audience for
participating today great conference
held by
agilent um keep giving us those
questions
welcome mauricius oh we still can't hear
you
there should be a little area at the
bottom of where your video bridge is
that will allow you
to unmute and you just kind of click on
that
and it should turn green
nope um
[Music]
thank you audience members for your
patience
this occasionally happens so we thank
you for your patience
right down at the middle of that um
that screen the video bridge you'll see
an area and it'll have a microphone on
it and you can unmute it and if that
doesn't work to the right
of that where your picture is where
we're seeing you
you should see a little area where you
can change your microphone
to the right
and again thank you so much for all of
your patience
i do want to remind you that agilent's
conference is a two-day conference and
there's going to be some more
great presentations tomorrow and
we um welcome you to participate in that
so
please join us tomorrow as well
and i know we'll have mauricius up in a
second
there's also a great exhibition that you
should check out
it's awesome as i said earlier
agilent always goes all out
have you found that yet it's going to be
on the bottom right of your screen
in that area where your picture is there
should be a little
area when you kind of put your cursor
over it
and a microphone will pop up
and as soon as that microphone pops up
you kind of have to move oh i think i
heard you
hello yay
how wonderful yeah sorry about the
technical
troubles i guess those are kind of
common things
we have the best audience members at
labyrinths
so i didn't see a single person leave
welcome thank you welcome and we're so
glad you could participate
um mauricius let me give you that q a
question one more time
all right okay again i want to encourage
our audience members to submit questions
and any questions we don't answer today
will be
answered via email um after the
presentation
by our presenter what are the challenges
of doing
unknown screening with current
analytical technologies
okay well thank you um
there's still quite a few challenges uh
in the unknown targeted
untargeted screening today so
most of them are related to having to
having no
universal technology so you still need
to use both
liquid chromatography and gas
chromatography to be able to get a full
picture
but not only that you also have
different
compounds that are ionized by different
ionization techniques so while you're
doing um
esi ionization you you get some sort of
results but
while you're doing apci ionization you
you might cover
different classes of chemicals
so one of the great challenges is still
trying to
to cover the entire unknown universe but
uh you still need to apply different
techniques like the
gcq dots and lcqs and the other second
great challenges on the data processing
side where
there's still a lot of is a big data
type of technology where
there's still a lot of need for a
uniform
type of data processing technology
thank you so much mauricius and what we
have to close today
um right now because we have no more
time for questions
would you like to provide some closing
remarks for our audience before we leave
today
yeah i would i'll just say like if
anyone is interested in knowing
anything about uh anything more about
niri or about the research on at our
group with prof shane schneider
please feel free to to reach out to them
or to to anyone at nuri
yeah thank you so much i want to thank
you both
dr schneider mr marquis dos santos thank
you again both of you for
tonight for today and i want to thank
our audience
for your outstanding questions any
questions that were
submitted and not answered today by our
speaker will be addressed via email
and this presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing through september
2021 please share it with your colleague
who may have
been interested in today's topic and
thank you again for your participation
and your patience and i hope to see you
tomorrow for our more
informative presentations at the second
day of the agilent
science and technology virtual symposium
and check out the exhibition hall
awesome until next time take care and
bye